so you all know that uh in complex
complexity Theory we are trying to prove
that uh p is different than NP these
guys will miss the punchline
and we can do it so we we just make our
life easier and easier and we go to uh
different fields
simplifying uh
simplifying the models to some extent
and one of the most interesting and
successful and still
largely open Direction in trying to
prove analog so be that different
guarantee was in the arithmetic
computation so many people here are not
computer scientists which is good but I
think everybody learned the four
arithmetic operations so that's all I'm
going to use
it's what automatic computation is about
what can you do with this foreign
to work over some field
which I will not really specify most of
what I'm going to say is to in general
or at least for infinitely sometimes the
only characteristics zero sometimes you
need more if you want to fix one just
think about the complex numbers but well
everything will be true but all the open
questions are interesting uh practically
over running and if it doesn't feel and
uh
now we want to compute things with this
arithmetic operation so the most basic
things to compute polynomials
what's a
most important polynomial in mathematics
it's the most important mode yeah it has
to be useful one I don't think yeah
that's okay yeah so I have at least one
friend telling me
foreign
Matrix
is this
thing that's very familiar to you
some of our permutation pi
products
x i Prime
so for example you would like to be able
to compute this thing and there is
complexity we want to ask you know
what's you know how many operations do
you need to perform in order to compute
this type of
polynomial you can assist about other
polynomials there is determinants as a
very good friend the permanent
this looks exactly so that's an N by n
Matrix of variables which looks almost
the same only that there is no sign
we'd like to compute this polynomial
asked how many operations does it take
now when we want to count how many
operations does it take it uh you know
makes sense to start defining a model uh
and the the obvious model is just to
look at the circuit of
you know composed of this arithmetic
operations you have the variables
explore some variables I mean here that
we have N squared but doesn't matter and
then we can just add them and multiply
them
you know
and so on until we get
some function in the output I want to
stress that we are talking about
symbolic computation here so what I want
is that
we are Computing the polynomial uh as
opposed to the function represented by
the polynomial over the field so if I
wanted to compute you know x to the P
minus X in a
they must be in the field with a plms
that's a different computation then even
though the function is identically zero
there I would like to compute this Okay
so
the circuit model is the most basic
model you want to count the number of
gates the number of arithmetic
operations you perform in this setting
and this is a circuit model
and there is also a formula model which
is a bit uh
weaker and more popular in mathematics
mathematicians normally in all
mathematics books you see just formulas
so rather than having parentheses and
stuff the way we like to think of them
is just trees that's the same thing so
again plus you know
plus times anyway the graph of the
circuit is a tree what it means is that
you are not allowed to reuse something
you computed before
okay so we have circuits we have
formulas these are the most basic uh
computational object computational
models and you know in these models for
example we want to know the complexity
of this uh
polynomials and for
some reason so there'll be lots of
models
or lots of settings where I will use
this talk is about non-commutative
computation but I'll talk a lot about
commutative computation so in in all of
them uh whenever we
talk about something called I will call
P
I simply mean what can be computed by
polynomial size circuits okay so so this
is the whatever you know we have a
polynomiality on N variables
maybe I should say
this morning as you notice they're on N
squared variables I will not distinguish
and an N squared because we'll kill both
things up to polynomials and will be
important that the grease are also small
so like these are multilinear
polynomials so the degrees at most the
number of variables but let's say so
we'll just care about things that
looks like this
and the degree
you know maybe some polynomial you know
uh anyway so be
will be the class of all functions that
can be computed by polynomial size
circuits and for reasons I will not talk
about now
and and see the class of
problem functions I mean polynomials
that can be computed by polynomial size
formula so these are polycized formula
formulas
and these are poly size
circuits
okay so I want to talk about you know
with the
complexity of such computations and to
organize my life I'll write you some
basic things that we we will want to
discuss in these various settings that
I'm going to talk about so one of the
sort of messages if you want messages
the
for the talk is that actually the
community the non-commutative world are
very different and there'll be many
you'll see many differences but actually
there's a lot to be gained from
interactions between the commutative and
the non-community world and all the all
the questions I'm going to ask are in
the commutative setting and are very
basic and everybody can understand them
and I hope that some of you will
actually solve them because it seems
that you'll see that
uh uh solving these problems in some
cases give us lower bounds on
non-communicative questions you know
on the complexity of non-communicative
computations and sometimes uh
uh upper bounds in the community words
give us uh really interesting upper
bounds for basic problems in
non-communicative computation
okay so it's more or less the
organizational
just State for the best load balance we
know so we'll have the circuit lower
bounds
the formula low balance
I'll just build the Matrix and we'll
start start filling it and we'll see how
far we go
and uh
then we have the these classes or the NC
class
polynomial size formula the class B and
there'll be also class NP so all are in
quotes
and of course we are interested about
you know we are interested in the you
know our formulas as powerful as
circuits is p equals to NP and whatever
it means in this setting I will not
Define it but we'll be clear what it is
for different reasons as we will see
because what I'll give you is sort of
complete problems for this for these
classes
and then there'll be two more issues I
want to discuss and one is the
polynomial identity testing problem
which you can think of as a for the
mathematicians among your word problem
for this model
the basic word problem which exists
essentially with any of the black
structure and I also want to talk about
divisions because so far
it talks about you know I talked about
polynomials and I want to talk about
divisions in terms of that uh would be
really interesting and Rich story to
tell you once we move to the
non-commutative world so
I'll just remind you some basic facts
about the commutative
commutative computation so here our
community means that you know all the
variables that we have commute so this
is the algebra is denoted
the algebra of polynomials uh
and uh we would like to prove lower
boundaries like to prove that I don't
know uh
the determinant is how to compute and
actually we know some lower bounds so
we know some analog and low bounce here
due to
stressen and balance lesson even it's
all it's even for determinant if n is
the total number of variables so we have
slightly super linear lower bounds and
that's
and it's N squared for I didn't say
which function so
explicit function
and for formulas we know slightly
stronger low bounds
oh
remember how to spell this
call it shenko oh anyway
there's some stronger formula but that's
what we know I mean we don't know any
better lower bounds than this we don't
have super polynomial low bands the
great open question and we are stuck
there but we do know some things here in
fact Valiant in the 70s built a very
rich theory of algebraic arithmetic
computation in particular it shows that
you know these classes have natural
complete problems so he proved that you
know complete problem for NC is
the determinant our favorite function
so I'll say in a second one in the
second most it means
uh
and uh
the complete problem it should be a
problem that in the class has polynomial
roughly polynomial size circuits but uh
every other problem reduces to it so
I'll Define it in a second I just want
to say that he proved the similar
results and very important
result that the class NP whatever it is
has a complete problem which is the
permanent for the permanent you know
this basic problem of counting matchings
in graphs is as hard as Computing any
polynomial you you can really imagine in
particular all the counting problems in
the world reduce to to this one and the
Valiant and his colleagues also
addressed this question here and found
something really peculiar that is more
real than uh
I think
we think is that uh
P equals Nancy
this variance Beyond velcro written lack
of
so anything you can do in polynomial
size in formulas in circuits you can do
also with formulas I'm slightly cheating
in general between polynomial and quasi
polynomial like Enfield organ but since
we are into exponential gaps
can allow me that so something which we
don't expect in the Boolean world this
literally means that everything
everything that can be computed
efficiently sequentially can be also
parallelized efficiently it somehow
happens in the commutative arithmetic
computation doesn't we don't think it
happens in a Mulan case and we'll uh
we'll see that it doesn't happen in the
non-communicative case
okay so let me Define what I mean by a
complete problem if you've never seen it
say somehow the nice thing about the
arithmetic theory that the variant
developed is the valence
is that uh you know it's very convenient
to talk to mathematicians about it
because there is no need to Define uh
any computational models it's just about
linear projections so what you say is
that a polynomial f
reduces to a polynomial G
iven no variables
if simply
f
equals g once you substitute for the
variable some are fine forms
of the air are fine
just a projection
and in particular so that's a notion of
reduction clearly if you have a circuit
for 4G then you can build the Circuit of
the essentially the same size forward so
that's a good notion of reduction and
this statement for example this
completeness statement uh when you spell
it out in this this language what it
says is the following assume that
F some polynomial
has the formula of sizes
this size
formula
then
f of x is
you know there is a there is an S by S
or 2s by 2s Matrix
filled with a fine form field
so aij
a matrix like this and if you take the
let me write it to us here
if you take the determinant of this
Matrix what you get is a Formula you
want so everything projects to
determinants of roughly the same side
everything that's a small short formulas
and the same holds for the permanent any
polynomial in NP whatever it is projects
to the permanent in exactly the same way
and it's really convenient because now
you can express the P versus NP question
just about as a question about linear
projection between permanent and the
terminal so P versus Zen p in this case
um
so what is p versus NP
in this setting it's just a question
whether the permanent
on end
and Brian matoses reduces to determinant
so P equals let me write it like this P
equal NP exactly if if and only if uh
determinant M for M which is some
polynomial line
so as many of you know that there's a
new project not it's the project is not
so new it's probably 15 years old uh
that marmali and suhoni started to to
try to prove this using what they call
geometric complexity Theory and actually
this topic will come up again later in
this in this talk in a somehow somewhat
weird way uh
but for those who are interested to know
what's the best known is there is a
result of mignon and Russia
showing that this m
is at least N squared
so we do know something although if you
think about it that's exactly what the
linear lower bound would be but anyway
so okay so we are
we covered this and of course I'll have
time for exactly
quarter of what I planned
um
what's the polynomial identity testing
problem so what would you like to know
I'll give you a circuit what's the
wealth problem in general I give you uh
you know a description of an object in
the algebraic structure and you want to
know whether it's zero or whether it's
the identity whether it's a trivial
element so if I give you a circus or a
formula and I ask you whether it's uh it
is a computer identically zero
polynomial okay so that's a basic
question and because of this translation
here
it's the same questions I give you a
matrix with variables and I ask you
whether the determinant is non-zero
whether the Matrix is non-singular and
this question has a very easy answer if
you allow yourself Randomness right I
mean you can just plug on the values to
the to the variables and compute the
determinant so you don't have to compute
the symbolic determinant just compute
the numeric determinant and you know the
answer so this problem is the
listing BPP so which means probabilistic
polynomial time algorithms can determine
the word problem in the commutative
setting the great stories and
connections to tell between this problem
and circuit lower bounds they are more
or less equivalent finding deterministic
algorithms here and proving lower bounds
here but I'm not going to go there I'm
going to go in a different direction
finally I just
uh
want to mention
the issue of division so in the
commutative setting
what what is division so here we are
interested in the field of fraction
which we usually denote
but we know that this is just you know
the elements here are just ratios of
polynomials you know p over Q right this
is what
rational functions are in the
commutative study and what's really
beautiful and again we'll come back to
this is that struction showed in the 70s
that uh so you can try to compute the
rational function by Computing the
numerator on the denominator separately
and the question is whether it costs you
more than you know because then
Computing it without divisions questions
whether it costs you more and this
result is no it's it's up to polynomial
the same computation so you might as
well if you are in the commutative
setting you might as well just deal with
polynomials and forget about division it
can be eliminated efficiently so here we
have efficient elimination okay so now
questions
so now I want to move to the
non-commutative setting
and I want to talk about polynomials so
here we have what's denoted usually
with these triangular brackets to say
that we mean non-commuting variables
okay
so we want to you know everything stays
the same of course whenever you multiply
elements you have to say who is on the
left and who's on the right and you want
to compute polynomials which polynomials
for example these polynomials but again
when you specify polynomials you better
say you know the older the order of
elements in a monomial are important
community
uh
although you can grow that
now thumbs are commutative and you know
you can ask what what do we know so what
do we know uh and look you know the same
lower Bound in the community so I should
say the commutative setting is even as a
non-communitive setting is even more
restrictive it's harder to compute
everything that you can compute
commutatively you can compute uh
anything that's so you can compute
non-communicatively you just forget
about ordering and you can compute
preventatively so low bounce Translate
uh
uh but here for the first time we have a
really low real low bound and this uh to
the end
low bound of Norm Nissan and this is
about 30 years ago so for formulas uh
formulas we can prove exponential lower
bounds fall if we are in the
non-communicative regime for which
polynomial as well for you know for
example for determinant
for permanent
and even for
functions
in p
so there are functions that can be
computed by circuits by
non-communicative circuits of linear
size which require exponential sites you
know communicative word and so here we
have
no
it does that well no no it's not in NC
it's not in NC
formula these are formula lower bounds
yes exactly right so we have no idea so
let me just write it we don't know this
right so formulas are weaker than
circuits but we don't know whether the
terminals can be well we'll soon say
something more about it but okay
so we have an exponential lower bound
that's great this 30 years ago nothing
happened yeah so question no
nothing happened since we would like to
prove circuit load balance and we don't
know how to do that
and I'll suggest a way to do it but let
me just complete this uh story here
um
it turns out that you can uh so these
are here are all these complete problems
for and see you know in in work with the
you'll die of
what we call the highway paper
foreign
you know there is the same reduction as
there
was a similar reduction everything that
has a non-community formula can be
projected to a
non-communicative determinant when I'm
saying non-commutative determinant
permanent in the usual ordering let's
say in the whole order just the way it's
written it
and similarly here
and
if it was somewhat misleading because
you know we more or less realized that
what he did can be converted very easily
to the non-commutative case so we again
seem to have the same complete problems
but why is this misleading so let me not
write it down but
tell you uh about one of the you know
really
need approaches to compute the to
approximate the determinant over the
integers over for non-negative matrices
so we know it's a health problem we
cannot compute it exactly and we might
be interested in approximating the
permanent let's say counting
approximately how many perfect matches
the graph has
it turns out that there is a beautiful
algorithm using Monte Carlo methods by
uh Jerome Sinclair and Vigoda
but there's another completely different
way of doing it
that was initiated by also Alistair
Sinclair and Mike Luby and Las Rasmussen
and continue with the arister and Steve
Chen
which com tries to approximate the
permanence of a non-negative matrix by a
reduction to Computing some
non-commutative determinants of some
random elements from a large Clifford
algebra
and the the whole complication is mainly
boiling down to estimating variance
which they showed that you know work so
everything should work except
that you need to be able to compute the
determinant of
a matrix of matrices right n by n block
Matrix of environment matrices
and that they didn't know how to do in
fact nobody knew how to do until it was
clear that it cannot be done because
the determinant
is the result of the permanent
in the non-commutative setting so in
this in this language that are used for
projection uh we have sort of the
reverse of what's happened here so in
the non-communicative set circuits we
have that the permanent
indeed reduces to
determinants may be in N squared
and scored by N squared size so the
terminals permanent are completely
indistinguishable they are both out they
are both complete for MP in the
and so you might wonder what's happening
here I mean that's certainly a hard
problem but not
not a complete problem but it turns out
you can you can make something
reasonable if you look at nearly
triangular matrices then you know it's
still
well basically it's complete it's still
hard and it's
it is related to the whole sequence of
you know it starts from Godzilla and
Goodman and then carving Carmichael and
the list of other people than barbino
can many others but the culmination of
this was the approach of you know really
going to lastly for the algebraz and
reducing the variance to
what you need that
the papers I mentioned so okay and
finally let me mention something about
this uh
yeah so yeah
the roadbound works even for two by two
matrices yeah yeah even for what they
are quaternions yeah yeah it's amazing
it's already as powerful as yeah
uh
what about uh you know polynomial
identity testing I'll give you a formula
which computes a non-commutative
polynomial
uh is it as identically zero polynomial
the identically zero polynomial
now actually you probably realize that
uh
many of you know that there are non-zero
but here where the non-commutative words
starts to be weird and it will get
really weird
soon
there are non-zero polynomials which are
zero on every
sequence of elements in the field you
know you of course you know this
right that's an unzero polynomial which
is identically zero of any elements in
the field any element in the field and
there is a more General complete
understanding of of this as the whole
theory of polynomial identity identities
but amiture and Levitsky
showed that uh
if the degree of f
is at most n
then
it cannot be satisfied by all
environment matrices
so then there exists and I'm one two
of that
F of this
effect of matrices is not zero
okay so what you can do and then once
you realize this you realize that you
can you know do the same randomized
algorithm and this was realized by
bogdanov and V so also here we have a an
efficient probabilistic algorithm for
computing the word problem
so let me now talk about proving Role
Bounce here so how do you move long
bounce here we don't know but in a
another paper and that's my first open
problem here another paper with the
uh same Highway guys
Highway another Highway
uh
we put the following things we we showed
that uh
putting a load Bound for a very simple
and in fact classical
uh problems that's the main reason I
chose the this topic for this conference
this neoclassical thing that everybody's
been joking about I I
knew that I have to provide some
a famous movie some of the names of some
famous dead dudes
anyway uh
I have here I haven't distributed those
who want can can pick it pick it up here
summarizing some of what I'll say and
and more
but this is classical problem which is
the sum of squares problem and
everything you know about some of
squares forget because it's a different
sum of squares problem then everybody is
talking about uh
holds the key to proving lower bounds in
non-commutative settings so what's the
problem uh
you you will agree with me if I write x
1 square times y1 squared
X1 y1
squared so far I'm sure everybody's
happy so this is for single squares but
suppose I I want to do for samples of
two squares yeah sorry very thank you
thank you
so on this board everything is
commutative
squared
times y1 squared plus Y2 Square
is it the sum of squares
well of course it's a sum of squares I
can open it up and it's a sum of four
scores but this is the sum of two
squares and it is because I'm sure if
you know X1 y1 plus X2 Y2
12 plus X1 Y2 minus X2 y1
Square so it's a sum of two squares this
was realized very early on by many
people in the Firma but long before
uh so that's great so
maybe it takes sense can we do more
and uh
I think 7048 Euler
did them first you know already in on
trivial one
squared
so it's a Z1 square plus Z2 squared but
this 3 squared plus the fourth squared
well of course that is you realize they
should be bilingual forms so the eyes
of X Y by D now
okay so one two four immediately now
people saw what's going to happen and
then Hamilton
or maybe okay I guess well I'm not sure
Kaylee and Grace
so did
or did the case of eight and now
everybody knew exactly what's going to
happen so they went for 16. and I think
many of you know this but they got stuck
and then the person who put them out of
their misery was orbits
and said only
one two four eight
there are no such identities if you want
exactly n times you multiply some of
them and squares by another sum of N
Square you want sum of N squared doesn't
work but it just leads to more questions
right whenever we have so suddenly we
can denote by let me call it s of n the
minimum k
such that when I sum
and
I give the sum of
k z I's
then wait we know it's possible right so
what's the minimum
k
okay that's a nice question people study
this it's a it comes up in several areas
not just this comes from division
algebra all these guys but there are
people in topology in fact this question
is exactly the topological question of
finding a bilinar map
from SN minus 1 cross SN minus 1. to SK
minus 1 these are the Spheres in
appropriate dimension in terms of
so I can ask you know what's the minimum
and people ask this and what do we know
well let me
put some you know
this can be done over any field or ring
because we have a definitely have a
solution of n Squad just in zeros and
ones
so people started actually mainly as out
of
fan and it's I said it's at most N
squared
and it turns out to be at least two
roughly 2N this is a deep result of
chains
a device topological result in terms of
that the upper bound can also be
improved it's a
N squared of a login
as a result of random and hovits but
anyway you know somewhere between dinner
and quadratic so it's not going anywhere
in the exponential lower bounds we want
and effects it doesn't seem to be
related because it's a commutative one
so what we proved in this paper
here
is the following so we put two results
if you can prove
over the complex numbers
what are the complex numbers you want to
prove a slightly super linear lower
bound
and to the one plus Epsilon for this
number of squares you need
this implies that permanent
and
has
a required circuit size non-commutative
circuits
guys
okay so all you need to do to prove the
response a Long Branch just to prove
this super linear Rover
others industry
lower bound through
we slow down this one yeah yeah you're
enlarged enough yeah
um so we prove this and then we try to
prove the lower bump but we couldn't the
only thing we could do which I can
assure you is much easier although
yeah
is that if you walk over the integers
then there is a lower bound
and to the 60s
there is a robot
but you know it's in some sense it's a
monotone type of lobe
so I want to explain it anyway so that's
the first challenge okay
very complete yeah
so that's a very concrete problem so I
want to give you another very concrete
problem that will go to the last part of
the talk which is what happens with
divisions so let me write the problem
five to two
it's a completely different problem so
I'm Switching gears
so suppose so the scholar Matrix
yeah so let's look I just erased it but
the Matrix as I I used before for the
determinant projection looks like they
had some affine forms here so we have
some variables x i and we had some aij
of this Vector of X so this is a matrix
sometimes it's called the linear pencil
or those who like this terminology so a
is really the sum of some Matrix as a I
so just the matrices over our field
times x i so that's a linear pencil
there may be a a zero like constant term
but I won't bother with this okay so you
have some Matrix like this and suppose
then let's call any like this invertible
this in quotes
if
you know I can replace this exercise by
large masses
by loud mattresses so that the Matrix
becomes invertible okay so invertible in
the usual sense because I'll put
numerical matrixes here so it's
invertible if
the exists K and Matrix says let's call
them I know M1
up to M let's say there are n of them
here it's not lots of generality to
assume that the size of the Matrix and
the number of variables is the same
so a man such that
this Matrix which is now
numerical Matrix over the field is
invertible
but you know that's a definition
okay and what we want
we want the an upper bound we want K of
n
we want an upper bound if such a if a
matrix is invertible we want to say it
can be done with matrices which are
small they are not that large give an N
okay they want to say girlfriend is the
smallest
integer such that
whenever the problem is true we can take
okay some K which is atmosphere
so there are always matrices with this
small case
uh it's a question
I would conject cell and uh so I'll tell
you some stories about this
let me conjecture even though it's just
a question we don't really have an
intuition for it is the polynomial event
uh I will not have uh time to tell you
all the stories I want to tell about
this I want to explain how it's coming
from this non-commutative world but this
is a now a commutative question right
it just said whenever you can replace
them with loud matrices you know you can
replace them with small matrices and
make it invertible so it's not a
commutative question
it studied a lot in commutative algebra
this type of question and in fact uh I
don't know
some people here would recognize Taylor
should recognize
that uh
it's related to the GCT question to the
geometric complexity uh Theory question
it has to do with the so-called
connected coefficient problem I don't
know how many uh people know here uh
about this problem has to do with the
understanding uh certain questions in in
a representation Theory and uh
you know people in algebraic geometry
and variant Theory are trying to prove
this kind of thing
so now I want to tell you we didn't you
know we don't work in this area so this
from now on I'm talking about some
reason work with the robes
um
we arrived to it's a completely
different way so it turns out if this is
true then some things in the
non-commutative world you know become
efficient so let me tell you which
questions
right
so I'll go
yeah so we need to move to the
world where we are non-commutative and
we have division
so what is this world so the first thing
you can ask you know is what happens you
know
can we eliminate division in uh
um or what in fact what are these you
know what's the analog of rational
functions here in the non-commutative
world so let me just give you some
examples so you'll see how weird this uh
world is
do I have 10 minutes
or not five minutes yeah five minutes
yeah so I'll just give you some examples
and I'll tell you what
um
you know if I write in we are in the
non-commutative world if I write you
know in the community world we said
everything is a ratio of polynomials if
I write X inverse plus y inverse you can
really convince yourself that there is
no way to write it as a ratio of
polynomials
so not everything is a ratio of
you can look at I know
this cannot be written at the ratio of
polynomial so you say maybe you can you
know
you can think this should be your
monomial then you should explain or
something like this there is an
interesting one so uh suppose I write X
plus you know
uh X Y inverse
yeah X
universe
now is there a message I mean we can
write expressions using plus times
divide and you know multiplication
division but the question what can how
do they simplify
and sometimes in this case you can
remove the nested inversion this is in
fact famous
um
identity
it's called the hua's identity which is
the
underlying What's called the fundamental
theorem of projective geometry so those
you know some weird simplifications of
nested inversion and you can wonder
whether you can do it in general but
it's a highly non-trivial fact that if
you write a similar expression here z y
inverse w
and you take inverse again
then you cannot remove this message
inversion
it's impossible and in fact one of the
most important theorems in the field
is a threaten now well
which
says that there is a you know this
inversion height is the infinite the
inversion High hierarchy
so the number of steps you can there
will be expression that you cannot
simplify with any number of nestled
inverts isn't
in fact it pulls the strongest theorem
it proves that you know he tells you
what is the hardest in some sense
uh you know rational expression
and actually you think about it you know
we saw that as in the beginning what's
the most you know important polynomial
in the commutative world and some people
said determinant and I I agree so what's
the most important
polynomial or rational function in the
non-commutative world
the terminal 3 results at the terminals
before but it's clear there was an
arbitrariness in the definition of order
of monomials and in fact people
struggled with it for many years and
what do you ever need rational functions
for Universal functions to solve the
null equations right I mean if you want
to solve x equals what
X it will be you know you need to invert
uh
you need to invert a or if you want to
solve a linear system
so Matrix inverse turns out to be the
most important not rational factor it's
a set of rational functions one for
every entry so what retina approved that
if we take an unbind Matrix
and invert it you know and we write the
entry the rational functions in the
original entries this requires
I think
and I'll just now that I am running out
of time I'll just fill the entries
without telling you too many too many
details about about this thing some
things follow from this and others you
know
don't but here's what we can do in this
uh
paper with rule by so it turns out that
because of this fact and because even in
the non-commutative world with division
uh formulas can be balanced we can get
an analog of Nissan theorem here so we
can get the 2 to the N lower bound even
for functions
in p and in fact the function in P is
this function X inverse so inverting a
non-commune system generic is in
polynomial size circuits but requires
exponential size formula which goes back
to
Alistair Sinclair the and all the other
guys approach to the approximately the
permanent maybe what you need to do is
not compute determinants you should
compute something which is computable in
the non-commutative world and use the
inverse of a matrix of maybe block
random Clifford algebra we tried it I
know we couldn't do it but anyway so you
can prove uh lower bounds here so I just
want to tell you what happens what does
this problem influence in this world
and what it influences
are these two things the last two things
uh
I give you a rational expression is it
the identically zero expression that's
the word problem
we don't know but if the answer to this
conjecture is true then so the
conjecture
will imply a BPP algorithm
what about
elimination of division we saw we saw
that in the commutative World it can be
done for free within polynomial overhead
we don't know so I should I say that
this is open
but that's what happened also here it's
open but if the conjecture is true then
there'll be an efficient
elimination
or up to polynomial factors of divisions
so let me stop here
thanks
questions
yeah
we'll see what happens
I don't know what happens well no I know
what happens overall in that we can pull
lower bounds over arm not for this
problem but for some other explicit
polynomial you can you can see that uh I
mean
maybe it's not obvious but this
particular polynomial the sum of squares
of the axis and sum of squares of the
Y's it's a particular polynomial of
degree four
by quadratic polynomial uh we said that
long bounce foreign
for some other by quadratic polynomial
that's explicit that will will have the
same purpose if it was over complex but
but what I can say that you don't need
to prove the low bound over the complex
numbers it's okay if you do it even over
the gaussian integers
somehow I mentioned that our long bound
over the integers over the rules is a
monotone lower bound it's a monostonal
bound because the square root of -1 when
you square it becomes -1 and allows you
to do negation and that's what you don't
have in
zero out so that's the reason yeah
anyway so that's what we know
does it make sense to
enter the community and not communicate
by imposing some relations I mean for
example if you think of computing say
basic expressions in a group algebra
some group some relations it makes
perfect sense and it was in fact studied
studied a lot in the some of the
contexts that I uh mentioned so for
example uh in this proof that the
terminal is as hard as permanent
initially what they proved it is for the
generic determinants determinant over uh
you know three variables but then a
subsequent work I think Alistair it was
you and Chen and the Alvin and the
universal right
um
sorry uh put the
the same even if you have you know lots
of relations based very interesting
specific group algebra's in fact I
mentioned the quaternions or two by two
and they characterize and some for some
you know of these non-commutative
algebra as there is you know it's not
that powerful so they know more or less
exactly so it makes perfect sense in
first started there
and a good question I mean I don't know
but probably we should start
yeah so for the complex problem you need
you need the two the all the times to be
by linear yeah all the towns are by
doing now otherwise yeah I should
mention here something really curious
which is uh you know related in some
sense to humid stock in the morning
uh you can ask what you so I mean in an
infinite field uh if these are if the
zis are polynomials then they might as
well be bilena it's very easy to see but
you can say suppose are not polynomial
suppose I allow them to be rational
functions just like with this belt and
Outing and everything well it turns out
that if you allow
the VR is to be rational functions then
you can have identities like all these
one two four eight for every Power of
Two
so if you replace this by Linear by
rational function
then there is a fist of theorem
which says that you can have any
rest of anything
beautiful
in fact these handouts which have all
the identities up to eight also have
it's the first page of a paper
explaining this
uh personal functions so those of you
want to see
self-reference so could you start with
the answers
I
with the x's and the Y's being rational
functions
yeah it's commutative so because in the
community world everything is simple
then the answer is yes